marie magazine des patins dans une
grande surface
arrivé à la tête elle sort son porte
monnaie pour payer ses patins c'est
alors que la caissière louis xi dans le
ton qui n'admet pas la réplique qu'elle
veut fouiller son sac à dos même si
mairie n'a rien à se reprocher elle a
l'impression qu'on la traite comme une
voleuse
elle proteste la caissière lui montrer
ce moment une affiche qui dit que le
commerce se réserve le droit de fouiller
les sacs des clients marie se sent
obligé de laisser la caissière italie
ses effets personnels
la vendeuse avait-elle le droit de
fouiller son sac
si elle ne veut pas non la charte
québécoise des droits et libertés
interdit les fouilles abusives pour
fouiller votre sac
le commerçant doit avoir un motif
raisonnable de le faire par exemple si
un agent de sécurité vous a vu rendre un
article sur une tablette il caché dans
votre sac
le fin mot de l'histoire un commerçant
peut décrire tout ce qu'il veut sur une
affiche
c'est la loi tient le dernier mot